all right guys this is Pete peppers and
this is a quick tips video for the new
soda fizz a feature the bottle caps
level mode in candy crush soda that just
came out today have some people asking
in the group so I'm gonna pause this for
a second what it said was that we have
to make matches to make a fizz and then
we continue to match that same color and
the fizz is either consolidated or it
moves to one so let's watch what that
looks like so I match the orange that's
the orange and I get a soda there's a 1
dot of fizz then I match it again and I
have a second one right so what I want
to do is I want to keep growing that
until it spreads so now we have one in
the four and when we match that with
those two over there now you see it it
shoots out and if you look closely I'll
pause it the next time it you know add
another another fizz to the same color
so it's similar to like the pepper panic
thing it's not quite a bit that's cool
but it's pretty it's pretty cool so we
got a couple with three three soda
fizzes on them I went ahead and made a
match with one now it has four the blue
one matched also like a color bomb here
we could technically match the color
bomb with the blue and that would spread
it but um that's not what we're talking
about at first so let's just so you saw
that I made that to the four and then
you can see these other ones grew at the
same time
and now as each one explodes you see a
multiplier and basically what we're
gonna do here is we want to set off
these blue ones that we already have and
you can see that the wrap candy will do
that too because when it explodes by it
it also grows it so we get a little
chain reaction going and notice that
they're all sort of in the same place I
noticed when I went through the
the higher levels here that it's not a
bad idea to kind of like pile them up
instead of move around so much just
because whenever the specials go off and
things like that then you get a you get
like a literal chain reaction and so
we're gonna start from scratch this time
we got a few with fences on them since
we had a nice cascade there so you can
see join those two with this and I got a
four gonna make this coloring candy here
most likely match that with the striped
and that'll spread fizz all over to
pause that so look how all the ones that
it get hit add an extra bubble to it
alright so it happens kind of fast but
just kind of check it out
a big so a big combo like that if you
have some fizz is going to both both of
the specials that I had had had fizz on
them so you know you're gonna basically
guarantee a chain reaction and a bubble
rush there and this will give us our
second cap and you know like just real
quick the multiplier it doesn't not once
it starts it doesn't always go to 6 so
if you find that it's starting but then
it's fizzling out mm-hmm there's nothing
wrong it's just that there weren't
enough there weren't enough candies with
fizz on them to contain the chain
reaction so we're gonna start from
scratch one more time we have to cut
where they got our last bubble cap here
so our soda cap and we got three with
fizz so we're obviously kind of match
those so just watch what happens
whenever those three get matched
together see how there's four now so
it's like three plus one there we had
one and we think we that was just one so
it multiplied the two same with that one
the orange with that will set this off
and I'll I'm gonna pause again let's
watch while this explodes you see most
of the yarn
have one or none watch when this
explodes how it spreads out to the other
orange colors see how it's it's
spreading to that color so that's that's
how you get the that's how it spreads so
even if the chain reaction doesn't start
now we have fizz all over the place that
we can match to start another chain
reaction it looks like it is going to
start so that's pretty much the gist of
it a couple of drawbacks it's kind of
hard to tell the colors of the candies
whenever they're on there so you have to
look a little you have to look a little
closer sometimes the general rule is
that it it it seems a little confusing
because it's it's new but if you don't
relate pepper panic it's really similar
to the to the that feature in that game
so what you want to do is you want to
match match the candies with fizz get
that that number of fizz to increase on
each on the piece and then when it does
it'll it'll explode which will spread it
around the board and then just keep
doing that until you get the chain
reaction started like I said earlier the
one thing I noticed was if you put it in
if you put a bunch of them in the same
place and then the chain reaction will
start a little bit easier because the
whenever specials go off and things and
that'll spread right to several of them
instead of just one and just play around
with it you'll get it just keep an idea
of what those three opening screens are
I hope this video clears that up some
and for me after a couple levels it kind
of really made sense so I think you'll
probably feel that way too I hope this
helps you clear up some things and
please like the video if it found
helpful make sure you subscribe to our
channel so you can get more how to play
and regular level video guides I'll be
talking to you soon thanks